um you mentioned earlier investing in
index funds
uh while being in kind of this culture
of
stock picking uh maybe talk a little bit
about how you think about your portfolio
construction today and how you choose to
get
various exposures just so as we kind of
talk about more of the nuanced financial
um topics people understand kind of the
perspective you're coming from
yeah so i've written about this a little
bit in in the past but my entire net
worth
is this house a checking account and
some vanguard funds a little bit of
berkshire hathaway and that's it
that's that's everything i love that
simplicity and i value that simplicity
that's i i would not even recommend that
that is
the that that most people or even you
know some people like that's what works
for
myself and my wife and my kids because
to me the metric that is going to make
all the difference in the world for me
over my lifetime
as an investor my lifetime as a human
and as a father and a husband
is going to be how long can i remain
investing for and i know that if i
dollar cost averaging the index funds
and i leave them alone for
30 or 40 or 50 years i'm gonna hit every
one of my financial goals and then some
and therefore like that's to me that's
everything that checks all the boxes of
what i want
i don't aspire to be the world's
greatest investor i i aspire to be a
great writer that's what's that's what's
important to me
but for me to go out and beat the market
on averages you know this year and maybe
i can keep that going for a couple years
that's just not
important to me but i it is important to
a lot of people and that's why i i'm not
a passive
zealot i'm not one of those people
banging the table saying everyone else
is a [ __ ] who's not doing this
to me it's just this works for me and
everyone's got to find something that
works for them
and i want to spend all of my bandwidth
thinking about the psychology of money
the psychology of investing
and none of my bandwidth thinking about
what what industry is going to perform
well in q3 that's just not i don't have
any interest in that whatsoever
so to me it's just kind of like finding
your own goals and what works for you um
to me i i also have i've just embraced
just as part of my personality
that i have a lower risk tolerance than
a lot of people would for my age and
income and net worth
and i'm okay with that i don't try to
fight against that or try to you know
change who i am this is who i this is
who i am
like for most people or not i don't know
about most people but a lot of people
our age anthony would be
what matters to them is like swinging
for the fences making a lot of money
and what really matters to me more than
anything is that i can go to bed every
night and look at my wife and look at my
children
and say you guys are going to be okay
we're all going to be okay we got
whatever happens we can we can withstand
a category 5 storm like we're going to
be okay
that to me is that's my biggest goal but
i know that's not a lot of people's
biggest goal so i always love the phrase
uh personal finances more personal than
it is finance
and i think we need to embrace that more
in in in
the financial twitter communities and
whatnot that there's no one right answer
for people
and a lot of the debates that we have
about this person thinks x and this
person thinks why
they're actually not debating they just
have completely different goals that
lead them to a different
area and they have they're playing a
different game i think that is a
a very rational view of the world uh and
one that is missing
quite often especially in uh was it 240
characters
hard to share that nuance um talk a
little bit about
uh you have relationships with and uh
one of the
the impetus for this question was uh you
know many of the best investors in the
world from a pretty
objective um just data-driven manner uh
many of them are on you know fintwitt on
twitter uh and then other relationships
that you have
how do you um kind of gain comfort and
really have the patience and discipline
to do
what's kind of best for you when you do
have all those relationships or i think
a lot of people they kind of fall into
i don't have access i couldn't do that
anyways but when you do have potential
access
how do you still kind of remain
disciplined and really it's kind of a
more of a
how do you control your psychology right
as you uh have this plan
well i think there's two parts of it one
is to me
there's really not a lot of temptation
because of what i just said about
what is really important to me is just
you know thinking
if i can dollar cost average for 40
years then
every one of my financial goals is going
to be met times 10.
so for me there's not a lot of just
temptation of like oh i can go do that
and to me the idea of
hey if i invested in in better funds i
could earn higher returns this year
to me i would almost put that in the
bucket of yeah and
if i got a second job i would i would
have more income
this year i i almost kind of equate
those two some people like maybe that's
not the best
the best analogy but that's kind of
where i put it it's like
i i could earn higher returns investing
in other funds but it would pull me away
from
things that i really like and from like
the psychology of thinking about my
finances in a way that is really
appealing to me which is
super simple really basic i have all the
numbers in my head because there's only
like four assets that i own
in everything it's really it's really
simple for me and that's just that's
just how i like it and it
if i can do that and meet all of my
goals
then why would i want to do something
else that's going to be more complicated
or more risky
i think maybe that's a big part of this
if there's one part of
my and my wife's personal finances that
i'm most proud of
it's that we have gotten the goal post
of financial success to stay pretty
stable over time
and i think for a lot of people the goal
post is always moving so when they have
higher income
better investment returns they get a big
windfall like
if the goal post moves in tandem with
that then you never feel like you're
getting ahead
but for us like the goal post has stayed
fairly stable so even though as we have
gotten ahead over time incomes have gone
up the market's done very well
you know this is the the worst economic
crisis since the great depression and my
my index funds are up like 12 this year
so it's like if like if you can have
that and your goal post stay steady then
to me like then the appeal of doing that
much better kind of diminishes
like if i had way higher aspirations
back to my
my when i was 19 that i wanted a bentley
and a house in the hymn if i still had
those aspirations then i would be
chasing down
my great investing friends to try to get
ahead but since i i
i don't um it's just like what i do now
checks all the boxes that i need to yeah
it's pretty interesting like
if uh you almost think of it like a
percentage basis the difference between
120 and 130 percent of your goal
just how much extra effort would it take
to to get that extra 10
seems to uh almost not be not be worth
it in some cases for some people right
right i mean i'll give you one example i
won't get into the
to the details but we got a modest
financial windfall two years ago um
it was it was it was meaningful as a
percentage of our net worth like it was
pretty meaningful
and when i told my wife about it she she
just said
is this gonna affect how we live and i
said no she said she said uh
that's fine then i don't i don't i don't
i don't she she just didn't care
uh it was just it was like nothing and
for a lot of people it would be we got
this windfall or we can go buy a
bigger house go for a bit and for for
her it was just like well if it doesn't
change how we live then who cares just
like it's just a game it's just the
numbers on the board that doesn't
and i i love that moment because that
was the best indication of like
our goal post has stayed steady in a way
that we're totally content with it's not
like we're
holding ourselves back and saying we
would rather go out and spend our money
on this but because we want to be frugal
we're gonna we're gonna deny ourselves
that pleasure if we can actually
legitimately remain comfortable with the
go
post where it is i think that is how you
gain actual happiness
with your money because now everything
that we save since we're not
spending it on stuff every dollar that
we save is just like a little bit more
financial independence
that will let us go out and live
whatever life we want to live retire
whenever we want to
live wherever we want to it's just a
level of control over our time
um that that is meaningful to us in a
way that
you know a higher level of material
living is not necessarily important to
us
absolutely and maybe talk a little bit
about um
you spend you know most of your day if
not all of your day thinking about
financial markets psychology of money
like things that are related to money
investing and markets um how do you and
your wife kind of think through
financial planning right there's a bunch
of people who've come on the podcast in
the past and
uh one person in a relationship is uh
well-versed and spends all day and kind
of like it's almost like their
occupation or related activity
uh the other does not and so kind of how
do how do you think through
um almost this uh arbitrage of
information right it's not even
education as much just like
somebody's reading all day about
something and somebody's not so how do
you kind of um
you know fit that into the model of
creating a financial plan staying
disciplined et cetera
especially maybe even in terms of chaos
as well like where you just might have
you know better access to information so
i guess there's two important parts of
this one is that we've been lucky and
that's that's the right word it is just
dumb luck
and that my wife and i see completely
eye to eye on spending
which for a lot of couples that is that
is not the case and that's a big
big issue so um you might i think my
wife and i have been together since
maybe she was 19
i was 21 something like that so you know
the majority of our adult life
and the number of spending disagreements
that we've had like i'm sure there have
been a couple but i can't think of any
it's always been really
pretty eye to eye so that's a huge
component of our personal
finances the other component is that she
is
much smarter than me she has a high
school diploma she went to high school
unlike me
but just like leaving that i said she's
much more analytically intelligent than
i am
but she has no interest in our finances
whatsoever
to the point where like once a year i
gotta have to sit her down and like walk
her through
like our like where we keep everything
but because of that it's kind of
just the level of trust i guess like i
100
control the financial decisions not
because i don't want her input of course
i do
it's just she's not interested in that
so i so i do that
on my own um so if i guess from a
planning perspective
our month-to-month spending has always
remained
roughly stable there's not a lot of
change i guess we have two kids now so i
guess there's been like
an uptick due to that but what we spend
money on hasn't changed that much
in a long time um so after so there's no
like okay we're going to spend x and say
why
we spend on whatever we want to but but
what we want to spend on is not
as you know of a huge portion of what we
take in so after
after after we spend whatever we want
then i dollar cost average into index
funds the same amount every month
max out retirement funds um and then you
know
there's been some some differences over
time my wife was working for a long time
now she's staying at home with our kids
so that income went away and then we
just bought this house so there was a
big
financial transaction there so it's not
perfectly stable over time
but it's just i think when you have a
when you have a big gap in between
your your spending and your when you
have a high savings rate because you've
kept the goal post
you just have so many options about what
you can do with your money which makes
the decisions a lot easier